hey guys it's me Alex I'm with my wife
and her boyfriend Don Terrace we just
found out uh we're pregnant dantarius is
the father and we're here to do the
gender reveal so
twisted honey
[Applause]
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the host of prime time with Alex Stein
on Blaze TV Alex Stein welcome to the
Reuben report I don't know why I'm
talking like this well no because it's
Primetime 99 you want to have the high
energy levels because I got to go insane
for the Ukraine Dave so this is why
we're gonna go for your audience this is
prime time 99 I need you to watch this
show there's like a million people
watching this I'm begging you please so
let's get on with this interview before
I go insane for the Ukraine too much
Stein you are on the short list of
people I consider funny I used to have a
lot of people I consider funny now
there's very few of them for people that
don't know you had you become funny
where did you come from what's going on
here well you know I'm really not even
that talented I'm basically I was
dropped on my head as a child I say that
jokingly but I really was actually had a
metal crib because I broke so many uh
wooden ones because I was kind of a
rambunctious baby but I think that my
formula for comedy it's very simple all
I try to do is mix absurdity with
reality I try to make the most absurd
things
seem real so that when people watch it
they're like is this real is this fake
and then that questions the reality in
which we live in and that is a formula
for humor because you know this as a
broadcaster as a comedian all anything
that's funny has truth in it so you just
mock the true status quo that they're
trying to ingratiate and trying to make
us all follow you just put a mirror up
to that acertainty like Dylan Mulvaney
and people will laugh
is that uh how you wake up in the
morning like you're just like opening up
the phone looking at Twitter going okay
they're just writing it for me and I
just gotta get out there with these ding
bats and make it happen dude I say this
all the time I'm basically a hack
comedian I don't even have to write any
material I mean the left gives it you
know sometimes we can make fun of the
right but you know this Dave is that we
have a unit party and you see all this
stuff with you know I obviously you're a
political commentator but like you know
you see The Strife between DeSantis and
Trump and all this political stuff it's
all lame it all sucks really at the end
of the day it's very important to save a
republic I'm not saying that it's not
important but listen uh politics is just
Hollywood for ugly people so it's just
all Annoying It's all political theater
and it's really easy to mock because
it's so absurd you know it's funny one
of the reasons that I people know that
every day I'm I'm applauding DeSantis
because I think he obviously is worthy
of Applause but but partly it's because
of what you're talking about I think
he's ushering in an age of sanity and
it's like the guy needs some help doing
it probably would not be great for you
but it might be good for the country no
and honestly you know for the content
Kings this is how you can tell the
mainstream media the people that suck
that nobody watches I mean literally I
bet your views are better than CNN's but
what I'm saying is they want Trump so
bad so when you see the mainstream media
is against the scientists all of a
sudden I'm like oh that kind of makes me
wonder too and listen I love Trump but
he had a lot of mistakes with Julian
Assange that you know people January 6
and I mean could he correct those yeah I
would hope so I would think that would
be the first thing he would have to go
after and write some of the wrongs that
he did but at the same time to say
DeSantis didn't handle Florida well
you're absurd it's like that's what I
don't get is that we can't you know we
can't see the force for the big tree in
front of our face we need to take a 30
000 foot View and objectively judge
these people and not try to create false
narratives in order to make the person
that we personally like sound better now
speaking of false narratives you're
you're often out there as the it usually
is the lefties rampaging through the
cities burning down things protesting
they don't know what they're protesting
and everything else uh you've been hit
with things people have spit on you
you've probably had to ask said pour it
on your head I mean do you ever really
really feel like you're going to be uh
hurt or something we'll put a little
b-roll so people can see some of the
video right now as you as you talk us
through some of this stuff well yes I
mean I go into these events and these
people are on ten different uh
antidepressants they're probably on you
know some sort of hormone therapy
replacement you know that doesn't mess
with your psycho you know your your
psyche at all I'm sure uh so yeah I mean
these are very impulsive people that are
there looking for they're they're there
to protest and I'm the villain and I
actually have a background I worked at
you mind I know this I worked for the TV
show Cheaters for a long time so I kind
of have a background in reality TV and I
hate to describe it like this because
this is a serious situation but this is
the Ultimate Reality TV when you go into
these these you know uh Hollywood
producer Central Casting they couldn't
when I went to San Francisco and I went
to this trans rally they couldn't pass
to these people I mean they couldn't
literally these people with the blue
hair it was every cliche under their
rainbow was there and so when you go
there and you put a camera people want
to see that and yes I I am nervous
because they throw hot coffee on me they
hit me but at the same time it's like
when a dog chases a car they don't know
what to do when they get there so it's
like you know at the same time they
don't want the smoke I'm 6'3 I'm 250
pounds I mean I'm a big man but yes or
is there somebody there that probably
wants to take me out there are people
there that wish for my death so yeah I
mean it is a little nerve-wracking but
at the same time that adrenaline is kind
of fun in a sick way too dude yeah well
I can see it kind of feeds you when
you're out there but for sure like when
you have people right in your face and
throwing stuff at you it's not the most
thing you'll probably appreciate this
about five years ago I did an event in
uh somewhere up in Canada maybe it was
Calgary uh with this guy Maxine Bernier
he's head of the libertarian party in
Canada and there were tons of protesters
there they're calling us Nazis and all
of this stuff you may remember the video
there was an elderly woman in a walker
trying to get across the street and the
antifa's calling her Nazi it turns out
that her husband actually fought the
Nazis anyway they're smuggling Us in
through the back so that we didn't have
to you know go through the mob and
someone threw hot coffee on me and I
remember thinking once I realized it was
just coffee and I was going to be okay
because you always have that moment like
what the hell was that I remember
thinking wow I just had hot coffee
thrown on me like pretty good pretty
good yeah but Dave you just described
exactly how I describe it it was this
warm liquid it wasn't burning hot by any
means you know they had had it for a
little bit but it was like they said
urine what is this you know they throw
cold water that's a little more pleasant
that you know if you played football or
played Sports everybody Splash cold
water that's not that's a little more
wakes you up when it's warm liquid
you're like oh and then when you realize
it's coffee I guess it's a little more
pleasant than like just a warm urine
hopefully not you know
hopefully not urine but they drank out
of the coffee probably so it's already
got some of their spittles and they you
know it's got the viral shedding in
there and you know I've probably been
vaccinated just by going there I've been
vaccinated by proxy uh but just going to
these events and bumping uglies with
them
were you always a politics guy or was it
more that you just wanted to be out in
the field with people and then it kind
of presented itself Dave forget politics
suck I was just telling you this I'm a
full-blown tinfoil had conspiracy
theorists I don't trust either side I
believe that they're literally listen I
I hate to be like this you know but I
honestly believe that people in power
are anti-america for me we are not being
run by human beings Dave we were being
run by multinational corporations you
look at Ukraine you look at Raytheon
Halliburton these corporations that
benefit from this America has been
totally
de-industrialized we don't create
anything I don't know what industry we
have other than bombs bullets some
crappy planes that they can't ever you
know they spend trillions of dollars and
can't even fly the plane some of these
you know uh secret projects that never
get off the ground so my point is we
have so much bloat and so much wasted
money a hundred billion dollars to go to
the Ukraine and there's everybody on the
right no we have to help them we have to
help them forget about the Ukraine let's
go help our Southern border I mean I see
this every day and I'm not trying to
Virtue signal or anything but Kamala
Harris they make it such a big deal oh
my God there's 20 immigrants at her
house I'm in Dallas every day I walk
around Bachman Lake it's a lake near an
airport there's tons of immigrants with
a backpack you can tell they have like a
fresh Walmart shirt and they're wearing
a mask because they don't really know
what the protocol is they're you can
tell they're new and oftentimes they're
just walking around just looking for
something to do so it's a serious
problem and I I'm not anti-immigration
but I'd like to actually not get kids
sex trafficked here and not get kids
overdosing on fentanyl at record rates I
mean so that's why I just see a unit
party we could stop a lot of these major
issues I think we could but instead
we're more interested in getting
everybody vaccinated making sure Ukraine
has vaccines making sure we have a new
aircraft carrier so Lindsey Graham can
go and bust a bottle of champagne on it
I mean it just pisses me off
not here in Florida my friend but yes I
get your point in the rest of the
country that's pretty much what we're
doing I want to throw to a video because
uh speaking of how they just hand you
people comedy you went to the committee
on Transportation where was this yeah so
this is in New York City and this is my
wife's boyfriend ontarius who's
basically he's also kind of my muscle at
a lot of these events especially the
ones in New York you know a lot of
people they hire professional private
security not me I want the least
professional no uh you know no insurance
no nothing so this is Don Terrace and I
complaining about a lot of the
transportation noises that are caused in
making homeless residents you know
making their lives difficult
videotape and we're talking about
Transportation I'm here with my wife's
boyfriend it's just ridiculous that you
you guys are going to persecute him
because he's a black man that's why you
guys are doing this this way you're
bringing so much attention to him when
we walked in here it was absolutely
unreal the amount of security that he
went through compared to the amount of
security that I went through and this is
my wife's boyfriend I mean the things
that he does to my wife is incredible
and we're talking about Transportation
let's talk about Pete butterjudge the
transportation secretary and he's the
best secretary we've ever had because
he's a homosexual and as a matter of
fact that's why I started to become
bisexual to be more like Pete
butterjudge and that's why I've started
to have a relationship with men on the
side and that's why I have grinder so
listen we need to get Federal funding uh
selvina is that how you say your name
Selena Brooks Powers
um we got to get some federal funding
from people to judge because listen Joe
Biden's over there I know his son's
smoking crack in the Ukraine but that
doesn't matter I mean Pete butterjudge
you know I know he's like on a gay
cruise with his husband and they're you
know like breastfeeding their babies and
stuff but they can help the
transportation issues we're having here
in New York I mean that's the federal
Boss Dog I'm Primetime 99 I'm a pimp on
a blimp so I wrote this song New York
City
is so dang bad
this apple is rotten
what have we gotten nothing but violence
all I hear is Silence from all leaders
my man's titties are out and they are
bleeders because they get cut with a
knife he sleeps with my wife this city
is damned too expensive to get an
apartment we need to lower the rent but
instead we're going to charge these poor
drivers more money but all I want to do
is get vaccinated stick that vaccine in
my arm I want to vaccinate with this
love charm I love you guys I'm Primetime
99 sylvina and my wife's boyfriend has a
lot of issues and you know I just hate
these trucks when they're trying to take
a nap and I'm playing Xbox and they're
trying to make love these these trucks
are making too much noise and they're
just polluting too much gas and they're
just making it difficult for my wife and
you know her boyfriend on Terrace to
really enjoy that thank you but you
everybody else got to speak past the
time limit so I just have a couple more
minutes so what I'm saying is in this
city we have serious issues and my songs
aren't going to solve it and we have
Eric Adams in the nightclub you know
doing God knows what sir if you're not
going to stay on topic I can't talk
about Eric Adams is he not on topic
we're talking about truck routes that's
what I'm saying so is Eric Adams not in
charge of the city is he not in charge
no I'm not finished I'm not finished I
just understand what everybody else gets
to come here and pontificate for five
ten minutes and I try to talk about
something and you try to shut me down
why is it because I'm a homosexual is it
because I'm bisexual thank you is that
why
I think they don't like that I'm
bisexual
all right
anyway guys thank you so much
um I might G bomb please help the
homeless uh it's a serious situation out
there I have to deal with the
you know the the trucks and all that as
I'm trying to sleep on a box on 42nd and
I think it should be addressed uh
homeless people are people too and um
I'm a veteran of this country titties
and all
those are veteran titties Alex people
may be wondering what do you mean your
wife's boyfriend uh dontarius before we
get into the specifics of the content
there which was you know there's a lot
to talk about
well yes obviously for the people that
are playing at home I'll in professional
wrestling we call it Cafe that's why the
Undertaker stays in character but I'll
I'll give you guys because we're on the
great Dave Rubin report this great
program I'm doing my trump I'm saying uh
because we're here I'll break the cave
I'm not married and uh dantarius is not
really my wife's boyfriend but what I'm
trying to mock is there's so many people
and content creators guys like Destiny
and and really there's just a ton of
people that it's like cuckold Society
where they just let their wife or
girlfriend be on only fans so really
that's kind of what I'm mocking and when
people hear it they laugh but I'm trying
to actually kind of bring attention to
the fact that literally we have a
society of like these demasculinized men
where they just let their wife do
whatever they want and that's happening
this polyamorous you know it's just it's
it's a little more common than we like
to say like to think and then when I say
it like that it kind of makes people
wonder you know what's really going on
with people's relationships and it's
funny it's just funny to say my wife as
a boyfriend yeah that's what I said so
it really is a thing though right like
this is a little out of my wheelhouse
this is really a thing where
this is so I'm So Crazy Dave because
I've I've stormed bar stools Sports you
know I had a beef with uh you know and
Dave portno I really he invited me on
his podcast and then disinvited me
because he saw that I was anti-abortion
because I went to an abortion rally so
that's why I I took a dontarius up there
and sometimes he makes appearances on my
show so he's kind of like canon in the
Alex Stein storyline and that's the
weird thing about me is my hero is Andy
Kaufman that's what I kind of uh you
know want to Aspire to see that I see
that yes and so that's kind of why I
have all these kind of side stories that
are going on are they true are they fake
I kind of like I said earlier I like to
mix absurdity with reality and then it
makes people question what's really
going on like if you read my Wikipedia
Dave is written by Psychopaths it's like
the most negative thing ever but what's
funny about it it's like Is that real is
that fake so I like to blend that line
yeah well that's I mean the Andy Kaufman
thing now makes so much sense to me
because that's basically what you're
doing and speaking of kfabe like he
really took took the kfabe of wrestling
into reality and then he brought it back
to wrestling so he was like layering
this thing I mean really brilliantly
what an underrated comic he created the
inter-gender wrestling uh division think
about that I mean but you know what
sounds so funny we need that now people
like oh what's the solution these people
that are saying that that uh people like
Leah Thomas deserve to compete against
biological females it's like no give
them their own division that doesn't
make any sense he's the 490th ranked a
male swimmer then he's the top ranked
female swimmer obviously it doesn't take
a scientist to realize that they have an
unfair Advantage biologically so yeah
it's just to think that Andy Kaufman saw
the idea of men and women are going to
give them back to compete in sports and
then it's going to be okay it's pretty
brilliant he he really throw a little
b-roll on that too because Kaufman for
people that don't know what he did was
he would get up there as a as a male
wrestler and he would invite a woman
from the crowd and then he would
basically kick the crap out of her and
people because of Cafe people didn't
know if it was real or fake no they say
it was real he started on the David
Letterman he would call people out of
the audience and say I'll give you like
a thousand bucks or 100 bucks I forget
what the reward was if they won and then
uh he would just at first it started
real he would actually pin these girls
you know because he's a man he can
physically be stronger than women and
then it became where then he had to
wrestle Jerry The King Lawler in Memphis
Tennessee which was at the time the
mecca of you know wrestling that was
like one of the biggest territories
quote unquote so obviously you can tell
I love wrestling but uh and that's kind
of what I want my show to be like Tucker
Carlson but mixed with a professional
wrestling at the same time
was brilliant yeah I'll give you one
more wrestling thing I mean Jake The
Snake was my favorite you got anything
for Jake The Snake of course no Jake The
Snake's great I mean dude that era of
wrestling was the best with you know him
and the Ultimate Warrior and Hulk Hogan
and no that was the era that was the
good old days now I don't watch it I
don't keep up with it but Jake The Snake
he was one of the best ever dude the
snake dude come on Damien yeah
snake Corner what would he have uh he
had his own little pit yeah is epic yes
check the snake I'll tell you something
amazing about the Viper spit and then I
promise we'll move on you know that
there is this special unaired episode of
the Viper's pit because he had Hogan on
as his Audi as his guest at the height
of Hulk Hogan and they were supposed to
get into a fight but the audience was
siding with Jake so they never aired it
because they wanted Hogan to be the
biggest star of the WWF but more people
like Jake how about that no I I not I'm
not one enough you be I'm not gonna
one-up you because you know you're much
cooler than me but listen I've become
friends and I just made fun of how I
make fun of cuckolding people but this
is a real we're just a real podcast
we're getting into the nitty-gritty I've
become friends with a guy named Bubba
the Love Sponge who is actually the guy
that let Hulk Hogan have sex with his
wife have you ever heard about that you
remember that the leak The Gawker sex
tape that got leaked well this guy Bubba
the Love Sponge was on the Howard Stern
Network on Sirius he was actually a big
broadcaster there and he actually was
best friends with Hogan and this thing
came out Hogan won this lawsuit but this
guy I talked to I go on the show
sometimes he talks about Hulk Hogan the
worst guy in the world not that Bubba is
you know the most moral guy but he just
said Hulk Hogan had his own locker room
didn't you know it's called the
wrestling putting people over when you
let somebody beat you and it you know
helps you know put them over essentially
Hogan will never do it he would never
put anybody over and so he was the worst
Hogan is uh I spent a couple hours with
Hogan did you like him was he nice
I was in an office with me him and uh
Jimmy Hart for a couple hours yeah he
was totally cool couldn't have couldn't
have been nicer of course this I'm
saying you know he probably is a nice
guy I'm just hearing this from a guy
that has heat with him but it's just
funny because that I sit around and I
talk to him I go on a show all we do is
talk about Hulk Hogan that's why he's
bringing this up and I always make fun
of Bubba about Hulk Hogan stuff with his
wife but it's just this whole it's an
insane world we live in uh Dave and uh
you know professional wrestling that's
kind of what politics is I know to try
to bring it all back into this it's
really like oh I like this team because
they did this but then the next week
they do something like oh I hate them so
it's really just meant to entertain us
and kind of distract us from actually
you know going after these people or
solving the actual problems in my
opinion the line I have on that is that
we're sort of in The Show Must Go On
version of democracy and I think Trump
really understands that to a degree so
he's just keeping the show going again
that's why I've been so high on to Santa
this because I sense he's he's trying to
actually correct it in like a
fundamental way to get away from the
stuff that is good for your career but
not great for the country where Trump
you know Trump did stuff with the WWE
remember yeah
he's in the WWE Hall of Fame but
but still wrestling because look at
it and then you know I think it's Vogue
or vanity I forget which magazine said
that she's the third most popular
politician behind Biden and Trump you
know I mean obviously I don't believe it
I'm just saying she's up there why what
does she do because she's an old
bartender I mean you know it's all it's
all fake and there's 432 congressmen and
women you don't even know how
when I sit on Capitol Hill and I go and
I try to interact with him I'm walking
around their offices I'm like who is
this guy from Montana or who is this
called it's like you have to be like
Marjorie Taylor green you have to be
very like confrontational to even get
noticed to get picked out the damn
crenshaw's a few celebrity politicians
and then once you realize that's what it
takes to become that kind of famous
politician and I'm very good friends
with Marjorie but you want to keep your
name in the Limelight you want to keep
on pushing the envelope so I guess we
need more politicians that are trying to
make a name for themselves but at the
same time it's all kind of kfabe now
what's the deal with AOC you touched her
butt or something no my gosh no now I am
going to go to jail but listen in front
of her boyfriend Riley speaking of
cuckold he didn't do anything I saw her
and I said oh AOC even though you like
to kill babies this is at the time of
Roe versus Wade a lot of that
controversy
you're still very beautiful and I said
you're my favorite big booty latina and
she freaked out and it would not have
been a big deal day but she went on her
Instagram and made literally 17 stories
yeah this guy she's like reverse
selfieing on her phone you know she's
like oh this is the guy you know this is
this is him she's like literally showing
me on her phone she put me in the word
keep on going back to wrestling this is
the Wrestling episode she put me over
she's like oh this Alex Stein guy she
took my video and then she tweeted it
and then it got like you know 20 million
views on her page so I couldn't have
asked for a better result and I was just
trolling and at the same time I was just
making a compliment she's so pro-sex
worker she's so pro-abortion you know
she's a been a bartender for me to say
you're a big booty latina it was a joke
and she act like she's the biggest
victim and then she went on because I
did in front of the Capitol Police after
voting for like three or four hours she
came out it was late at night it was
like 11 and she said that on January 6th
some of the Capitol Police were
responsible for letting someone some of
the rioters in and that she didn't trust
some of the capital police she those are
her own words so
she's just uh you know it's easy these
people have very fragile egos so when
you kind of call them out like Dan
Crenshaw they sometimes melt like a
candle are you uh worried that the
higher your profile gets it'll get
harder to Ambush these people because
they know what's coming
well I mean yes but I constantly have to
reinvent the wheel like I can't just
always go to you know trans I'm done I
mean I'm gonna still go to these but
come on Dave you think I want to go to
another drag queen story time for
children in Brooklyn New York I swear I
don't even Jimmy Kimmel made it played a
clip of me doing an interview and they
said you know the guy's like oh sure he
doesn't like going to these dragons and
he's right I'm like
I'm like they're making money I don't
want to go to these events but so I'm
gonna have to remove it
politicians face I'm just gonna have to
keep doing new stuff I can't you know
it's like Andy Kaufman you gotta create
a new angle every day people know that I
like giving the devil is due that's what
I try to do on this program when you go
to the drag queen Story Hour and you see
the parents there with kids putting
aside the trolling for a second what
have you ever had a same conversation
with one of the parents even off camera
and like really what do they think
they're actually accomplishing by taking
their kids to these things well dude you
just nailed the real Crux of this whole
thing it's a lot of times and I've seen
this and I can see it with my own eyes
it'll be like two women and it's not
that they're lesbian it's usually
they're like heterosexual woman that's
getting back at their ex-husband or you
know that I've seen that multiple times
and then there's a guy Jeff younger who
his ex-wife is transitioning one of uh
his children to a girl that you know he
doesn't want and then you look at Dwyane
Wade who transitioned his son and
Gabrielle Union is the stepmother who
encouraged that and the biological
mother is actually a student tried to
stop it so that's a big thing of getting
back at people because people are so
vicious and I know that sounds crazy but
I see it with my own eyes and you're
just kind of like it's because I don't
see a lot of the two-parent households I
have seen that I have seen two parents
that look like they were you know the
mother and father of a kid but most of
the time it's kind of like a two women
or two gay men or you know what I'm
saying it doesn't it's not the
traditional families that I've seen go
to these events and that's the problem
these kids aren't choosing to go there
it's parents taking them there to be
edgy or to be ultra Progressive and
really I like I I think the parents
maybe their heart is in the rights you
know spot some of these parents I see
like maybe they're not so ingratiated in
this weird uh stuff but at the same time
there's no excuse to take a kid to a bar
or to a drag show or even a library I I
just I have very little sympathy for
these people but a lot of times it's
vicious I notice is the motivation I
think yeah are you ever afraid that
we're all butterfly affecting this thing
like you know it's existed for a certain
degree we push back we make it bigger
then they do it to outrage us we expose
them they outrage us we expose them what
are you talking about dude you see this
now that we've gone Ultra left now you
see the ultra ride to get mad at you
because oh there's a gay conservative
that has a voice you see that because
now we've gone all Ultra right so now
we've gone Ultra so that's kind of
almost the problem is we're Ultra
polarized and when most people are
somewhere in the middle so I think
that's kind of you know one of the
biggest problems I guess that that I
feel like as a society is now we're so
polarized you're right like this since
we since I went I exposed a drag queen
Story Time for Kids drag your kids right
of it now 10 000 more bars let's do a
drag event for kids so you're right
because I'm saying so the more you push
it you know the more the more farther
right people want to go the the farther
left people go so it's kind of this
weird dichotomy where they almost feed
themselves by just it's like a magnet
that doesn't uh stick together you know
they're just once try to push them
together we just become more polarized
what else you've been uh thinking about
lately are you are you doing anything
else well I guess you're going to
constantly be Reinventing yourself but
like do you do you like set these things
up like that's what I'm going to do next
month month after that I'm gonna do that
or is it kind of just what's going on in
the news at the time well to be honest
I'm kind of frustrated I recently went
up to a project Veritas to uh you know I
had a bit where I was gonna go there and
talk to the CEO about them ousting you
know James and that ended up kind of
getting messed up I had some you know
project Veritas insiders and then they
got kind of leaked so I'm just saying
you know I have some you know stuff on
the horizon where I want to go and and
confront some more people and I and
honestly the thing please guys watch my
show I'm there at the blaze grinding
every day I know I'm begging I don't
care I got a plug Dave in front of your
huge audience I go insane for the
Ukraine it's literally not telling
anybody to ever do LSD but it would be
like Tucker Carlson on LSD and he is my
biological father but no no honestly
Dave if you like what's bugging me the
most in society right now it's like you
know it's you know I want to say
politics but I I feel like there's going
to be in I try to be
spiritual or whatever but I just think
that if we don't watch out the idea that
you saw Tucker Carlson just put out you
know they want us to eat bugs I really
do and it may not be in our lifetime you
know uh you know you see all this
artificial intelligence this and that
but I do believe that one day they're
going to say because of climate change
they want us all to live in pods and
they're going to say here plug into the
metaverse and in the metaverse and here
on Earth you only live for you live for
like 70 years but in the metaverse you
live for a thousand years and I don't
believe they're gonna have the
technology in our lifetime but I do
believe and I hate to be black filled
like that I think that's the future they
want us to be all one sex or we
basically can't procreate so that they
can you know basically you know
depopulate the world and if you don't
think that's happening you know the idea
that they tell every single kid to get
an abortion yet every single person that
comes up through the southern border
comes from cultures where abortion is
basically you know just you know
despised these people aren't having
abortion so it's just kind of weird
they're basically depopulating us right
in front of our face so I just I think
for us as human beings we cannot point
to oh it's this country doing this it's
Ukraine doing this it's making my life
bad you know you are responsible for
your happiness you are responsible for
creating a life that makes you happy you
are responsible for doing a job that you
respect you like and not being a debt
slave and not being a slave to you know
social media even though you and I are
on it like crazy sadly I've kind of say
that hypocritical because I'm addicted
to social media but like I said it is
important for us to find our own
happiness and be our own you know the
man in the mirror you know this Dave
it's not the government the government's
gonna kick us all day long the right
side the left the right wing the left
wing are on the same bird so you are in
charge of your happiness that's one
thing I try to you know tell people when
they watch my show or whatever quickly
you were you were going black pill there
but then you shifted to the white pill
very quickly right the black pill is we
all end up in Matrix Ready Player One
Minority Report Total Recall and then
the the white pill is what you just said
there you don't have to participate and
you can carve out something on this
Mortal coil that's pretty decent for you
and it sounds crazy but if you really
look into it a lot of these people like
the Klaus Schwabs they have all these
Think Tank groups they kind of tell us
what they want to do you know they tell
us that they want to scare us with
climate change but if you just look at
people like Barack Obama who bought a
house in Martha's Vineyard or you you
look at Bill Gates who bought a house
and you know I believe like southern
south of San Diego these people are so
worried about the you know polar ice
caps melting why are they all buying
beach houses so it's just it's very
hypocritical they all fly on their
private jets that create emissions that
are insane so it's just if you really
kind of see these people aren't even
following their own rules then you don't
become a victim because uh listen Dave
now to get really sad I joke around a
lot but this is why I'm a man on a
mission you know my mother actually died
in October 2021 she was was short of
breath I begged her I begged her not to
go to the hospital she went to the
hospital
she was in there she was kind of she was
breathing we're talking we said no room
does Veer they gave my mom room design
she died five days later her her organs
filled up with fluid and she died in
front of my you know right in my arms
right in front of me and they literally
murdered my mother they did not have any
sympathy whatsoever and these are the
same protocols these people like Dr
fauci Who test his vaccine on eight
beagles so we really do have like a
medical industrial complex where I was a
huge victim so that's why like I like to
laugh because if I don't laugh if I
don't make fun of stuff I will cry so I
lost a person I love most in the world
and uh so that's kind of why I'm on this
Mission Dave to kind of call out the
absurdity because I was a victim of it
and I don't want anybody to feel sorry
for me do not your sympathy is not
needed for me I hate that when people
say I'm so sorry I'm not telling you
this to feel sorry for me I'm telling
you this to warn you that there are bad
things that can happen to good people to
my mom who got vaccinated because her
doctor said that was the thing to do
even though she knew you know it wasn't
tested but she didn't want to lose the
care of her primary physician so people
got bad information and I and my mother
were victims of this thing so I the only
way that I think I can call it out is
not by being necessarily super serious
but by mocking it because they mocked me
and they mocked my mom when they gave
her him deserveer knowing that it was
not going to help her
well then instead of saying I'm sorry
about your mom I'll do the one thing
that you want me to do which is give you
a chance to promote your show yes okay
probably time without
your mom is my biggest fan she's my
biggest fan that's the only thing that
sucks too now I work for Glenn Beck now
I got a cool Studio I got all this crap
going on I'm making a little bit of
change you know I'm acting strange
getting paid a little bit of Chase and I
don't even get to share it with her so I
want to share with you the audience come
watch my show you're gonna see me go
unhinged you're going to see me happy
sad every emotion because I'm Prime Time
99 I wear my emotions on my sleeve and I
just want to say thank you so much for
letting me come on your program and it
is an honor and privilege I know you get
hate but I think any hate not that you
get a lot of hate but I think that's
what it takes like if everybody
universally loved you and I then we
wouldn't be controversial or edgy so
that's what I I think that makes you so
special so Dave thank you so much for
letting me come on Stein I know you're
hunkered down there with Glenn Beck you
know sharing a bed in Dallas but you
come out to the free state of Miami
dinner on me yes sir yes sir all right
Dave well anytime so this this is device
reporter you can tell the only one in a
mask here so how are you doing just
doing my job she's here trolling
everybody here so she's the only one
here in a mask and she's just saying
negative stuff I can't believe they let
you in here do you feel like you're
lying are sheep in the lines then
um I have credentials to be here yeah so
do I what I'm saying see this is advice
guys this person she's trying to troll
this event she thinks all of you guys
are losers so that's what she posts on
the internet she posts the most she post
remotes out of context stuff see Vice is
the worst Media Company there is they're
all liars so what do you think about
your crappy media company
I know but don't you think Vice is a
bunch of liars oh you're proud of you
know you guys made me talk about drugs
are you are you a drug addict too like
all the vice content you make guys this
is the vice as this person sees a loser
right here she's the only one in a mask
you see this this is what a loser looks
like she's got her coronavirus how many
vaccines do you have
are you on are you on your fifth vaccine
none of your business oh my God it's
nice or why do you want to mandate him
if it's none of my business are you Pro
vaccine Band-Aids
guys you see this this is a device
journalist looks like she comes here
this is what advice journalist looks
like in a little mask at the
conservative event now she's scared
getting attention if you're looking for
more enlightening and maybe even
humorous conversations check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here and to get notified
about future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification Bell